the White House has finally put in place new
so called rules for reporters who want to
be in the press room during Sarah Huckabee.
Sanders is now very infrequent press briefings
and the new rules can be used to kick out
almost the entire press corps if that's what
the White House decides it wants to do.
There's something called a hard pass to the
pressroom.
Okay.
A hard pass is good for two years and it gets
reporters in the pressroom and on White House
grounds.
The White House doesn't want, uh, as many
people to have these two year passes because
if Joe, the reporter or Sally the correspondent
ask a question that the White House doesn't
like in month one of their hard pass tenure,
the White House now needs to deal with this
adversarial person that they don't like for
23 more months until their hard pass expires.
So what the White House is doing is making
it much harder to obtain or to keep those
hard passes they're claiming.
It's all for security reasons.
You'd have to be a moron to believe that that's
the case because if someone is really a security
threat, the secret service and the Capitol
police can easily say they need to be removed
even though they have a hard pass because
they are a security concern.
So the new rule is that reporters have to
enter the White House at least 50% of the
days over the hundred and 80 day period leading
up to the renewal, which basically means every
other day.
Um, but there are not actually that many days,
uh, during that 180 day period that those
reporters would potentially be going to the
White House.
And I'll explain because you might think,
well there's 180 days, the reporter needs
to be there for 90 of them maybe.
But if you are a White House reporter, uh,
for the most part things are happening at
the White House in terms of briefings only
on weekdays.
So you're 180 days to seventh, two sevenths
of those hundred and 80 days or weekends.
So that already kind of gets you down to only
128 weekdays.
So you've got to be there 90 days out of 128
weekdays.
So that means you need to be at the White
House 70% of the days, not 50% of the days.
But if you're part of the press corps, the
press corps often travels with the president.
And once you start putting together these
multi day trips plus some of the even longer
ones that the press corps attends to say that
they have to be there 50% of the days ends
up working out to a huge majority of all the
weekdays that the president is not traveling
and this is a ridiculous requirement.
And to go even further, Sarah Huckabee Sanders
is barely doing briefings these days.
She has had two news briefings this year since
January one 2019 she went 59 days without
a briefing.
So you're putting in place a requirement for
reporters to have to go to the White House
on the overwhelming majority of weekdays during
which the president is not traveling, even
though they're not doing briefings.
And there's no practical reason to be there
all so that they can say you don't qualify
to renew your hard paths.
And if you lose your hard pass, you need to
either get a daily pass or a weekly pass or
try to get a six month pass and right away
you become subject to the political whims
of the White House.
Whether they do or don't like your reporting.
CNNS Jim Acosta, a sort of a perfect example,
the Washington Post's Dana Milbank has had
his pass revoke this week, was notified via
email, says that there are other reporters
including all seven of the Washington Post's
White House correspondence.
And we know that Donald Trump doesn't like
the Washington Post politically.
So this is obviously politically motivated.
It is yet another way in which a Republican
administration that says they're for transparency
and says therefore all of the bs that the
right likes to claim to be for, um, they are
actually one of the most authoritarian and
tie media administrations that we've seen.
And meanwhile they continue to launch attacks
on the left, claiming it's the left who wants
to suppress speech, that it's the left who
doesn't want the real hard questions asked
and all of this other nonsense that they're
using to bamboozle voters around the country.
Extraordinarily heavy handed, anti media,
anti speech, pro censorship decisions.
And if you believe that this is all about
security concerns, I feel sorry for you.
I don't know what kind of a fantasy world
you're living in that you buy that explanation.
Yeah.
From the White House.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
Follow us both